so they're going live alright it says we
are live hello and welcome to round
table with the stream team and this is
where we talk to amazing content
creators and their journeys and where
they have become today we would like to
welcome to the roundtable med Queen 88
how are you doing great I'm happy that
you were able to join us I'm excited to
be here great happy to ask you a bunch
of questions and see you know what you
what you kind of experience and things
are going on we have the full crew today
we have was just amazing because it's
been so long we have old-school-style
how are you I am just peachy thank you
we have l-boogie I have to tell you you
sound super monotone oh thanks I am
trying my hardest right now to to push
through this and we have MJ today we
also got MJ sitting around how are you
doing but it's poppin' I'm doing good
doing good that is that is your phrase
what's poppin yeah we got the trademark
that Fat Boy and you're now definitely
and we have myself now though hime Here
I am very sick but I'm here for
everybody so we're gonna end up asking
make me now so why did you end up
wanting to become any content creator
man that's a rabbit hole right there
because I've been wanting to create
content probably for six years or more
and I for the most part have been just
on kind of different different avenues
like I started with the hair channel on
YouTube and I would do things with my
hair and post that stuff and then at one
point I was doing makeup and then that
kind of transitioned into oh my gosh I
love the show then you start making
videos about this show so I stuck with
like doing review content for his shows
for a little bit and then I was like
wait there's this thing that I do
literally every day and I see people do
it on YouTube
as well let me just start doing video
game content so then I pulled that in
and I started getting all the equipment
to create video game content whether
that be reviews or actual gameplay and
then I transitioned into live streaming
which to me is a completely different
animal it's a little bit more intense
it's on the fly and can be a little bit
cringe if you ever go back and watch
yourself but this is why I don't do that
right it doesn't ever go back don't ever
go back and watch yourself you're just
deceiving
what's in the past is in the past but I
think for me what made me want to be a
content creator is something that could
help me is not necessarily escape but
something different to do that's outside
of work outside of home home life
outside of everything that belongs to
multiple people whereas this belongs to
myself is something that I do for me and
it makes me happy so that's why I
decided to create content yeah that's
pretty cool I think I think Pete's feats
probably indisposed at this point so
what I figured
so how long have you been doing this
format like is like how I understand you
like you went from the hair thing to the
gaming thing but how long have you been
focused on gaming like what what's
what's that one thing that you like I
this is why I got to do it I say I've
been doing video game content for three
years
and the reason why I have to do it is
because video games is something that
has been a part of my life for a really
long time since I was a kid and the
person that introduced that to me was my
dad and we still game together to this
day he's been on a few of my streams on
Twitch like it's definitely something
that keeps me and him together as a
family outside of that he's really cool
like we're cool like that but that's
just something special between me and
him
in the sense that kind of when I
whenever I play a new game or if I'm
doing really well on the game I'm like
oh I bet this will make him proud so
it's kind of like a little bit of
sentimental value there and it's
something that I like to transition and
pass down like my kid I let my daughter
watch me play games I play roblox with
her so it's definitely like a family
thing for me as well did you know where
gaming experiences and stuff like that
from from him yes yes I used to watch
him play Doom old-school Macintosh and
he bought me my first Genesis and even
after that like he got me into city in
Europe he was like a big city of Heroes
buff like love that game he'll play for
hours and hours so he got me into that
that was really my first MMO so yeah I
still like even though he's old-school
PC gamer he hasn't really moved on
outside of that kind of thing I like I
still like to introduce just play a game
or watch his knee streaming that
connection now what what was the one
game that like I I know you say you
watch that you watched him play gym like
what's the one game that you two really
bonded over like what was that one thing
there's probably City heroes that's the
first like a game that we were able to
play together and still to this day like
if we play it today he'll like show them
something you can go do this it always
kind of ties into like that like sure oh
my gosh here we go nice like go over
here and do this and now this is what
you can I come back and let you create
this level I'm gonna go switch my
character and come back and I'm just
like okay now he's turned into this
whole thing this whole lesson that I
need to learn like this valuable lesson
that he needs to put on me now but it's
still really fun um but yeah I would
definitely say that that's what brought
us together and then I and then there's
times when I try to bring him into my
world like I try I play a lot of zombie
survival games that's typically what I
enjoy playing the most
and I tried to bring him in on seven
days to die and I'm like no dad you have
to go this way so I'm like yes my turn
to give you the lecture no this is how
you craft frames this is what you build
no don't do that it felt great I love to
be in the boss so is so it's a it's a
family thing not a composite competition
thing we don't get competitive
everything that we've attempted to play
together has been some sort of co-op
yeah never any competitive stuff in fact
I've never
the only competitiveness I've seen in
him in regards to gaming is when he
plays he plays a really weird game on
Facebook called what is that thing
called shadows of something and it's
basically like clash of clans and so
he's always like yeah I'm about to go
read these people like he gets really
dark with it I'm like okay it's digital
you're not really going to kill anybody
right now you get a relaxed but yes not
really anything competitive is usually
co-op whenever we're bonding over games
that's cool that's cool um so let me let
me ask you this like how did you start
out like what was where where was your
gear at and where you at now like what
were the steps you took to get because I
was watching you stream the other night
and it's it's a great stream qualities
there everything was there yes it's been
a long road it started off with me and
just like this really really cheap
laptop that I got from Costco I couldn't
even tell you the specs I just know like
the processor is like non-existent now
you probably could never find it it
probably couldn't even play a VHS tape
this is like that type of processor is
really just a weak laptop yeah and um
pretty much started off just like
recording reactions it's a video game
trailers or a video game like like jump
scares if it's a scary game or something
like that I started off doing that and
then the reviews for games that I
actually played
I think my very first gameplay was of
titanfall and I did it directly to
twitch from from my xbox and then pulled
it down edited it and threw it back up
on youtube and so that's that's where it
started at just using my laptop to edit
and not really touching on the
livestream aspect of it just yet I'm
getting you know my getting my own
console
I actually built my first PC which is
the content for that is actually on my
youtube - I was very excited to do that
and put it on YouTube so I built that
got my dog Otto and that's when I was
able to start live streaming but I still
was not that comfortable with live
streaming and like needing to engage
with people through a screen where you
think but I can't see them and you know
just kind of engaging with text I still
wasn't ready for that innocent so I
spent a lot of time just recording
videos and editing them and that's where
I was for a little bit for the better
part of a year and then then I started
building it's a live streaming first on
YouTube lifesaving on YouTube was
actually pretty good
but is like I was the only person over
there
so then slowly but surely a transition
my way over to switch and as far as
equipment I haven't done much more to my
PC outside of upgrading my processor
once and adding more RAM and adding a
heatsink began outside of that my my
setup is for the most part been the same
just making little tweaks here in there
getting a better desk getting an
additional monitor getting a better mic
and yeah just slowly adding on to it
it's a pretty expensive hobby yeah that
it is that it is have you ever thought
about switching the mixer um no and and
not because I don't think mixer isn't
doing its thing I think definitely
they're showing that they have the
ability to pull some some great content
creators and their platform looks good
you know there's nothing wrong with it I
just feel for me that I just did removed
from YouTube it wasn't that I just moved
from YouTube and you know I don't want
to end up in the plates where I'm just
abandoning something I've been working
on to move to the next best thing not
saying that I would never move but I
would definitely like to get my bearings
and yeah you figure out where my
sleeting is and streaming in general and
and then try to make another move after
that as we all say if Microsoft's came
and gave you a bag of money would you
move right now no one's paying me for
this [ __ ] now you did you did kind of
touch on something I think we all
struggled with it first and I'm kind of
curious how you got over it which was
the the fear of going live the talking
to nobody essentially for a little bit
how did you how did you get through that
oh I think I still struggle with it like
if I don't see anybody saying anything
for a while I like get like this weird
cringe feeling every time I look over at
the webcam or look over at like the chat
um I think for me how I got over it and
just like able to push through it is to
ignore it frame you and just pretend
like I'm playing for myself which at the
end of the day I think we all are is
it's not like we're playing so that
people can watch is that we enjoy
playing this thing we would enjoy
sharing it with people I think that's
the most important thing so I try to
always remind myself that this is
something I like to do for fun and I
don't want to put any stipulations on
myself like oh my gosh nobody's watching
I'm never going to play never been a
stream again so I try to always keep
that in my mind and you know this is for
me at the end of the day and if people
want to come through and share with me
that makes it better but it's not going
to break the situation for me cool I'm
gonna touch on the one of my favorite
things that you hit there so you're a
huge zombie game person huh yeah but
there's a difference let me stop you
right there alright so talk to me you
explain to me the difference there's a
difference between zombie horror games
and zombie survival pains okay I'm I
lean more to the zombie survival side
because it's less horror and more
intense situations a lot of them have to
deal with like crafting or building base
management and stuff like that so when I
say those I'm thinking like this beta
decay state of decay obviously first
absolute favorite game the first one my
favorite state of decay 2 is good some
things change that kind of took the I
guess attachment to the server to the
community people out of it for me but
it's still a good game and of course I
live to follow and it labs and I can't
wait to see what they do next yeah after
you tell him that you're gonna have to
talk about your relationship with him ok
yeah sure
yes sure so yeah I've been following
undead labs and stata decayed since the
first one drop I think it was like
2013-2014 or something like that friend
of my random friend of mine from like
elementary school hits me up on Facebook
I don't talk to this person right but
he's like hey you might really like this
one game and then disappears into the
universe he's not even on my facebook
anymore so the key it's like an angel
came down but it was like huge state of
decay and flew away and so after that
like definitely one of my favorite
zombie survival games and so I spent a
lot of time on my youtube channel either
streaming or creating videos for that
and I think that's where a lot of my fan
base came from or not fan base but
people that enjoy watching me people
came from
is me playing Stata decay and I think
that's what a lot of people know me from
know me for playing because it's been so
much time on it and you can tell when I
play it that I just really really
enjoyed it so after a while I think just
creating enough content
the devs from and it labs came through
and they'll hit me up every once in a
while they'll send me like a little care
package of stuff and you know are
they're open to all types of you know
suggestions and stuff like that and they
really try to do do right by by the
state of decay community so they're
really cool did you think about World
War Z it was fun it gave me a left for
dead vibes with a little bit of like not
RPG but you know basically able to level
certain things able to level your
weapons able to plants so I gave a
little bit more replayability then left
for dead but which what's strange is
that left for dead to me is still very
playable than World War Z like and play
World War Z and once I finished once I
finished all of the chapters on hard
yeah but I can just go back and just
play left for dead on on any difficulty
and it's just the funniest thing to play
especially so I don't know where was he
it was cool I wouldn't say it's like
what am i favorite it's not a survival
game they need to make left 4 dead 3
yeah yeah yeah tell them valve doesn't
do that and we know but yes I'll back to
the difference between zombie survival
game zombie horror games zombie survival
7 days ago I stayed a decade stay to k2
and then we have zombie horror games
which are your Resident Evil's
I don't know I guess you can stay what's
that guy what's that
I can't think of it Walking Dead no not
not Walking Dead I can't
the guy but he's after like his daughter
or something like that it's like really
Oh Last of Us not well not the Last of
Us
yeah snobby horrid one two yeah that one
two and then the evil within those are
more like yeah those are more horror
zombie horror games and I don't really
do those but I surprised myself by
beating red sunny evil to this my
playing games like that is for me well
don't play do not play outlast yeah no I
can't
I've seen it and I don't even know what
I was doing I did it's him to play the
evil within I don't know you know it's
like take your anxiety and just like
send it to the roof my heart is pounding
and waiting before I even press start on
the intro screen yeah but think of the
entertainment value on the stream for
life I never even finished was the one
the Microsoft just acquired the girl who
hears the witch he'll blame it LOL
pudding scary I don't know it's creepy
might the voices are creeping me out
voices already annoying me like I felt
like I could only play it with one
headphone off I can't have both all of
them all five of them chicks so ever how
many it was just like I'm taking one
headphone off see this is what we gotta
do
but yeah hopefully it was cool too I
like to play Blair Witch yeah I was I
haven't play it on a stream and I
probably only got like I don't know an
hour in but to me that wasn't scary
either it reminded me and it was funny
is because when I went to the e3
presentation and they and they showed it
on the screen they showed the trailer I
was like oh is this Alan Wake okay Blair
Witch but when I played it I was like
man this is Alan wait
they should just made this Alan wait -
so did you play it control no I didn't
think it's a little freaky - yeah it's
cool I didn't I haven't been able to
complete it because [ __ ] just keeps
coming out but yeah so maybe by next
June I'll be able to get to it what's
what's funny about the genre of games
that I like to play is that not all the
time
they're family appropriate or or even
children appropriate my daughter is five
years old but when I beat Resident Evil
2 I had to let her watch me beat up beat
up mr. eggs it's something I think I
want her to know that mommy could do if
we're I don't know mommy pretend to be
mr. eggs you know like you got a late
especially when your kids are young you
obviously don't want them to have like
weird nightmares and stuff like that but
it's it's good if you can isolate
pockets of good stuff like that to share
with them so they're like oh yeah mom
you can do it dad I could do it I can I
could kick ass - yeah so so now how do
you feeI
and this is you kind of triggered
something for me how do you feel about
her getting in the streaming like what
what do you think would be
age-appropriate for her if she's not
already out there doing it already
as no one knowing what's out there on
the Internet yeah I know it's crazy and
it's funny you ask that because um she
she likes to play games like she has a
slit she'll play Kirby or she'll play
just Just Dance on there she'll play
just dance or whatever um I don't I
don't know that video games are really
super her thing she obviously enjoys
watching me do it or or playing with me
because you know that's something that
we can do together but I think her thing
is more of those like toy review things
because she loves watching those and
then she took my she actually took my
phone one day and she was like I'm gonna
watch you two so I gave it to her but
then I get it back from her and she's
recorded like a 10 part series of her
plan were her dolls on my phone and it's
the funniest thing because she's like hi
guys in the comments I'm like what are
you talking about comments anything
about comments but it's just it's funny
that this I mean this is a whole new
idea of a career especially for younger
kids they actually had career day last
Friday do you know how many youtubers we
saw they had a sign of what they were
and it said youtuber for like I would
say like 25% of the kids there and some
of them had video game headsets on to
show like what type of YouTube where
it's the way that it's crazy it's what
kids want to do it's what they see it's
a huge part of their entertainment and
they really look up to these these
content creators and these streamers
that they enjoy so I think for her to
get back to your question you know what
is age appropriate to be a either a
streamer or a content creator I would
definitely like her to be old enough to
understand danger especially if she's
live streaming um and
understanding danger on the Internet can
be a little bit difficult especially for
children they don't really understand
that that person that's behind that
might not actually be that person that
you think they are
grown-ups kind of get caught up like
that so it would definitely have to be a
lot of discussions of what is safe what
is it and also kind of preparing her
just to kind of take things even further
prepare her for the fact that she is a
black girl and there's a lot of a lot of
stuff that comes with that a lot of
negative things that can happen for
being a woman of color on stream or as a
content creator so yeah I would
definitely you know just want to prepare
her at whatever image she decides to
kind of take on that type of hobby it's
a difficult question I don't even think
I answered it sorry no no that's it it
is a difficult question and I think it's
just based on however your parents so I
think I thought I thought you answered
it great so let's get back to you what
what do you like streaming like I was
what like I said I was watching the
other night so like what games do you
really connect with when you're out
there streaming it's usually a zombie
survival type game just because zombies
zombie movies just zombie genre anything
has always been something that's
interested me well before I started
streaming but I'll decide of of that it
it's really games that have really good
like fleshed out characters or something
that I can kind of attach myself to and
just find humor in it so one thing that
my streams the people that come through
to my streams really enjoy is if I play
Final Fantasy and the older Final
Fantasies like I'm playing Final Fantasy
7 where there's no no verbal dialogue
and I have to read everything so I kind
of come up with like these voices for
different people
and I'll add lip a little bit and we
just have a really good time doing that
it's hilarious it's
so that's always fun kind of just
getting into a character and even if I'm
playing something like like like the
outer worlds I'm a person that doesn't
there's there's no verbal back and forth
from me to the other person so I can
kind of come up with the way my
character sounds and even add up a
little bit just to kind of make it a
little funny so yeah things like that
like I can make it a fun and
entertaining time for the people that
are watching our games that I typically
grab a seat - cool I said when I was
watching it the outer world stream you
you do a lot of shoutouts like how have
you built a pretty good community around
you with other streamers and what have
you like how are you growing your
channel oh I can't even say that I've
done anything consciously to grow my
channel I just kind of just happened I
guess I delight to just run into some
really really really cool people and and
people that I want the people that are
at my channel to go check out because
because you know various reasons whether
I know them on Twitter and they always
have something funny to say we engage
there or if I've met them in person say
at e3 or or if I just known them you
know for a long time and a lot of times
it'll be people who started out as as
viewers of my content and then they
decided they now want to try the string
and I really want to encourage that you
know somebody came to my channel and saw
something in my content that said hey I
really want to do this try this for
myself you know I want to foster that I
want to help you know make sure that
they kind of have a leg up and and
they're able to be successful not even
saying that I'm all that successful but
it definitely depends on what you're
looking for as far as success I wouldn't
say I have a huge following but I think
the people that do come through are
really interesting and people that are
special to me so yeah so that's why I do
a lot of shout outs
everybody sees them yeah I definitely
checked out a few of them as well I just
it's just funny because I was looking
I'm looking at your chat and he and you
seem to be a pretty good inspiration for
most folks and and I don't know how you
feel about that that's a pretty pretty
big mantel to carry I don't even see it
I don't I don't see it as an inspiration
or maybe I just don't notice it but what
I'm engaging with these folks it's just
it's really crazy to me how a lot of
these people I've never even heard their
voice but I know their personalities
just through chat you know what I mean
is and I feel like that is so weird yeah
it's a good thing so it's like I have
all these different these different
friends that are pen pals in a sense but
I know their personalities I know their
humor and it's just really cool being
able to bring all these people together
and what's even weird is that's one
thing that I do like about you know the
readability on Twitch or hosts is
because it's it's like I don't know how
to describe it it's like it's like
singularity it's like that that one
theory that everyone knows everyone
through three people and I feel like
that's how the streaming community is
like someone might raid you and they're
like oh I've never seen you before but I
know this person or they meet someone
that they know in chat and then you
raise somebody else and they're like oh
yeah this person is like now all of a
sudden everybody knows each other it's
kind of like that and I feel like it's
funny I don't know it's a weird dynamic
no god it is weird but enjoyable that's
all I was gonna say so I'm gonna I'm
gonna put you on the spot here so what
are your top five games I'm stealing a
kognito line here if he's listening yeah
top five and it can be all time doesn't
have to be just now top five I have to
say Telltale's The Walking Dead Season
one I'll have to say state of decay of
course Final Fantasy 7 and Zelda Ocarina
of Time oh I love that game
I was that for that's for one more he
says that damn title different to like
incarnate ocarina I've heard it so many
different ways like not even funny yeah
yeah I don't know ot and fair enough I'm
a I'm a big fan of the Zelda series so I
can appreciate that one MJ oh you got
any questions so did you start out with
the elgato like internal or did you do
the external I have the external and I
have the exact same when I never
upgraded it the it was a hd60
yeah it's chilling so I have the HD 60s
but I see that they've now come out with
the HD 60s Plus right so that one's
gonna allow you to broadcast 4k do a
portable so you don't have to put it in
your computer because a lot of people
don't like having to put the one in the
computer because it takes up a slot I
find it but just like to keep talking I
find it so um how did how did your
family feel when you said you're gonna
like start doing all the
to work and all the the streaming stuff
how did that like kind of affect you and
them um I don't think I really told
anybody it's kind of just something I
started doing and then I'll randomly
like share a link on Facebook and we all
know Facebook is for family this is for
family and I think there's even like
people recently I think I'd shared
something on my wrong Instagram my
accident I meant to put it on my gaming
Instagram and my friend was like oh my
gosh you do that that's uncool and if
somebody like like doesn't even doesn't
play games but they're just like oh wow
you do that that's cool I've heard of
that either through like you know
nephews or nieces that do it or whatever
um so um when I was doing it and my mom
knew she she's like what's that she's
like I know you always like to play
games that was like a no-brainer but I
don't think she really understand it
like you know what like what is
streaming or with the kind is a lot of
people can't even grasp like why would
someone watch you play the game really
enjoy watching other people play games
but for me it's just really reminiscent
of getting together with either your
cousins or your brothers and sisters
whatever and sitting down and needing to
pass the controller or what or take
turns playing the game and sometimes you
just really enjoy a life for me I was
never able to play play Resident Evil
and stuff like that so I watched my
friends older bird that play Resident
Evil because I was too scared
and so to me streaming is kind of like
people that enjoy being a consumer of
streaming I think they kind of get that
vibe from it outside of that answer your
question like my dad knew that I was
streaming he thought it was pretty cool
like I didn't get any I didn't get any
negative association with it which is
good it's real good uh I know that you
said that you played city of uros a lot
I don't know if you know this or not but
there's
actually servers out now that people
have actually made videos for so that
you can actually play it again yeah yeah
yeah my past weekend oh ho nice yeah we
as soon as I find another to be my
friend of mine every day trying to get
me to help him set it up because I
wasn't working at first I was like a
doodad don't worry you're gonna be
playing in no time
yeah he was really excited and you know
it's funny because when they shut it
down because of that hole was a DC
universe or they had an issue when they
shut it down he said he was online like
when they were getting ready to
countdown for the for the complete
shutdown and people were like all in
like the lobby area or in the lake by
Lady Liberty lady shame like saying
goodbye like he was like he was so sad
and he and he hung it up on his wall
that's how into the city heroes so he
was yeah he was super exciting once he
heard that it was bad yeah I played it
during launch also I love the game it
was it was really good and very cool
concept and I actually preferred it more
than I did
DC Universe Online so it's kind of I
think the whole thing with DC Universe
Online is just it just engulfed the
whole entire populace of City of Heroes
because people they want to be
superheroes and they want to do that fun
stuff but unfortunately that's what
they're going to come down to is they're
gonna go towards DC because of the name
DC which is kind of horrible I don't
even think it was that I think it was
they were more upset that you in City
Heroes you can literally make any
superhero you can put your mind to and
so of course people were running around
making Iron Man and making Superman
making Batman people were running around
making it making these different
characters and they had an issue with it
they're like no you can't use our yeah
they weren't getting a row
teeth right there you go even though it
wasn't a city a hero's father wasn't the
creator's thought that the customers
were making these characters but there
was just so many options that you were
able to create these characters so I
don't know I'm glad they're back though
yes so when are you are you going to e3
next sure I plan it - yes York's I
assume you're excited about all the all
the announcements and things like that
yeah it's it's always a lot of fun
surrounding that the announcements and
then also just the atmosphere of it and
being able to run into pruning of people
that are also interested in the same
thing as you sometimes you end up making
friends in those very very long lines
and it's just a good experience overall
so I'll definitely be ready to go
hopefully PlayStation will be there this
time is the e3 the only convention you
go to is it's the only one that I've
actively planted to myself but I've been
to like WonderCon and this really small
convention called tech Leimert here in
Los Angeles but those were just because
I got free tickets to them that's really
the only reason those but I would like
to try to go to maybe PAX West one day I
think that's in Seattle or pack South
and in Texas but it all depends so yeah
so right now the one that I plan for the
most is either you yep so was there any
like challenges that you kind of
encountered when you first started
streaming
yeah and it's an ongoing challenge for
me and that's a schedule
and trying not to fall off of the
streamer map there's time like two
without streaming or doing anything
either just from fatigue or you know
sometimes you just don't feel like it
and that's just being honest and even
though it's something that you love to
do you know you can tire yourself out I
feel like thank you for saying that
because it'll act like you're not
supposed to say that like you just don't
feel like being bothered with anyone so
the thing that kind of a creates me the
most is that people think like you have
to be on it's and then they get mad at
you for not for not streaming and it's
like dude you serious I need I need a
day to chill so yeah absolutely and a
lot of times I think that might just
come from folks that don't understand
the type of energy and time that goes
into it because that it's not just
hopping on the stream it's promoting
stream it's creating create your own
channel art is creating channel art
frustrating it's setting your schedule
it's coming up with games that you want
to do first featuring she the type of
streamer that give aways planning
giveaways and and then you have to also
have the energy to Inc each live on
stream so it's it's almost like being
actor and that's saying that when you're
on stream you're acting but just because
it requires a lot of emotional energy to
engage with people like if you're giving
a lot of yourself there but you're also
being your own manager like if we're
looking at this as being an actor you're
being your manager you're being your PR
agent you're being your marketer you're
being all of these things that one and
then on top of that you have like a real
job and a real family
[Music]
I'm sorry God know that I was gonna say
that's what uh actually I've run an
article that said that people that are
growing up to be like streamers and
ended up like being content creators
they're almost like the best like all
around people like jack-of-all-trades
because you literally have to be a PR
person an HR person you have to be able
to be really good at paperwork you need
to be great at communication you need to
be able to get all these different types
of you know different jobs
in one area don't forget you got to be
the talent too yeah exactly you
literally have to be everything that's
really interesting then it does that
which to me I really like because it
helps me stay in touch with with my
creative side I do draw my own emotes i
do create my own channel alright and
it's just something that kind of keeps
me in touch with hobbies that i've
enjoyed throughout my whole life video
games art tech stuff it just kind of
it's all in one for me and so definitely
it's definitely something that I enjoy
doing like I said you get burned out
sometimes sometimes there just wondering
sometimes you just want to gain by
yourself know it my like today I've been
playing good it did take like for me to
like get into the game then I'm like
okay I know this this is fallout I know
what's happening
no worries coming yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly it takes time to rev up and I
had to remind myself of that too so yeah
for me I felt like it took like at least
the five hours and then boom it opened
but yeah sometimes you just just want
that time to either game by yourself or
sometimes you don't even want to touch
your keyboard controller sometimes you
guys want a binge Netflix but yeah sorry
lucky for me I have this the community
that I do have if you want to call it is
really accepting either my tardiness or
sometimes I just don't show up at all
but I do try to engage and let them know
this
at a time in discord on Twitter it's
been received very well I'm very lucky
do you feel it like most of the people
that have come to your twitch channel
have kind of migrated from your YouTube
page southern has not all of them though
like there's some people that I really
miss and like had great times on YouTube
but they're just like I just don't do
twitch that's fine so sometimes you know
I do try I have been trying to keep my
youtube afloat and every once in a while
I'll post a video there or some gameplay
there but that like that little middle
ground where I was at when I was slowly
transitioning over to twitch but i was
still balancing my youtube channel i
think that was the most stressful time
being a content creator for me because
it's like I'm trying to be live here and
then I have this video to edit for
YouTube and trying to balance that
schedule on top of you know regular life
stuff was just it was really hard and
stressful because you you put a lot on
yourself because you're like oh man I
have to get this have you ever been just
sitting down like eating dinner or doing
something you just think oh man I'm
supposed to stream tonight oh man this
video and you just like sometimes to the
point where you're almost dreading it um
just because you're so burnt out but
yeah it's good yeah the struggle is
definitely real when it comes with
balance and that so how do you balance
your home verse you're streaming like
like I know you said you were trying to
get on a schedule
like how do you balance it right now is
it like the home if there's something
going on at the home that's priority or
do you still have to like I gotta get
this stream in I tried my best to say I
have to get this stream streaming but
stream is unfortunately always the last
thing that needs to be done riveted so
kiddo her homework or dinner her bath
hubby his food
all that stuff comes first and then I'll
hop on and stream late-night so I'm for
the most part the late night streamer
everyone says oh yeah we try to catch
you you're one of my favorite late-night
streamers I didn't even know that was a
thing because I would say at least 75%
of my community are East Coasters I have
no idea they're up to like 3 o'clock in
the morning messing around with me and
I'm like what are you doing because I
would be mad out you're crazy
but you know I'll to support that and I
think that's amazing I can't believe it
sometimes but they do they show up
whether it's 12:00 midnight or 3:00 a.m.
they come out so yeah typically my
stream will start my schedule I try to
aim it towards the end of the week like
a Wednesday through a Saturday or Friday
through Sunday sighs deal and it always
starts in between 9:30 and 10:30 so
that's a huge window give myself yeah
our windows figure out what I'm gonna do
it or not do you feel that because like
you you're kind of forcing yourself to
your schedule it's helping you or is it
just kind of like it is what it is I
think for to do the schedule is better
than kind of having it up in the air
cuz when when I used to just say I'm
just gonna I have no schedule I just
dream when I can and and that to me made
it more difficult and more stressful
because that has me every day where I'm
like oh I think I should stream tonight
that was making it worse where as
opposed to I know I'm going to be here
Wednesday through Saturday if I don't
make it one of the days that's fine but
I know these are the days that I'm doing
this and it kind of gives me the
motivation to they let me let me go on
this these are the days that I I said I
would be here
need to try to hold myself to that and
be accountable for it
so how many hours do strand per week
usually I try uh per week I try to I try
to do like I really try to stick to like
2 hours 2 hours a night so what is that
that's Wednesday Thursday 48 hours yeah
I try to stick to 8 hours but it doesn't
always work out that way
sometimes I'll end up doing like a
random 4 to 5 hour stream and it's like
3 a.m. and I'm like no what am i doing
but sometimes you know you just get into
unit sometimes stream is going so good
and it's so fun you just chatting it up
you don't even realize how late it is
you kind of like look up or winning it
one of your chatters will do up time and
you're like oh snap I've been I've been
doing this as long oh boy yeah so I
don't time it I don't say stream is from
here to here I just kind of you know let
it let it go out however long it's
feeling then some nights there's been a
night where I've done like a 30 minute
or an hour stream just because like hey
I want to get on get a stream but I'm
super tired so we're gonna cut it cut it
here wish to me I feel like it's better
than nothing no better than just not
doing it at all no I I got a I gotta go
back to something you said what are you
watching on Netflix right now um we are
in the series drought right now I think
um so notice series really oh I finished
Jojo that animated JoJo's extraordinary
or whatever it's called that was day
I've watched a train to Busan a bit
focusing on a lot of the movies train of
thought was so good so you won't play
horror games but you'll watch train to
Busan be loved zombies
did you start watching debrie ken yes so
daybreak I watched the first couple of
episodes and it is did you finish it yet
no no I'm only two episodes in it I feel
like it's so over the top it's just
crazy gives it gives off a lot of like
early Zombieland comedy like I was just
so weird like how are these kids just so
the whole the whole premise of the show
is there's a nuclear war but the nuclear
war was like some type of chemical that
turned all of the adults into ghouls
essentially and all the kids survived so
all the kids are pretty much trying to
survive without adults it's really weird
yeah okay Zombieland - it's like the
first one was funny and then I'm glad -
they just like laughing about being
paste yeah copy pays on these times -
yeah well anything but looking you'll
probably know that when they were in the
bar and it was duplicate I wasn't yes
see so there was like it was obviously a
zombie land - yeah but it had some very
hilarious moments so I was happy with it
I think this time around they really
harped on like these characters are set
in the characters that they are and just
like yeah magnified their their
stereotype like who these characters are
they kind of like magnified it but yeah
it was good did you see Joker yet
yeah I haven't what that's it when it
comes on video yeah see I'm a person
that rather watch like movies at home
like me me and my wife will like sit
there and watch a movie and we'll end up
like pausing three or four times
throughout the whole entire movie just
so I get a drink or go to the bathroom
or something so they asked one of the
movies is kind of difficult I would say
that the only movie I have to see in the
movie theatres and Star Wars other than
that I really don't I don't know tickets
no I didn't get my tickets do you mean
there's no deciding on a day you either
go Thursday night or Friday I will
probably be going
December 25th 25th to 26 27 something
like that
yeah from the internet I don't care that
much in I don't care that much about the
only no fee I thought I watched in the
theaters get spoiled if you get spoiled
it spoil you know it is what it is it's
more of the other ones get spoiled the
other ones the other ones did not get
spoiled for me but did you watch them as
soon as they came out no done the same
thing every year okay Henry looks good
I'm not gonna lie I don't like him as an
actor oh yeah looking on my alright I'm
gonna put my face on you right now
please don't let me down but he was good
I'm not like the trailers like awesome I
can't wait because I was skeptical as
well but he looks really good so imagine
yeah does he look good because of the
wig or because it's him no because I'm
Wrangler
not even I just think you like he looks
I didn't believe he could look like
Daryl at least video game girl and he
looks like video game girl to me it
sound like okay
but this this is the pre one preview
game which is what five hundred years
younger
when did the books take place I don't I
don't remember I remember having a huge
conversation with one of my buddies
about it but it's basically before he
decided to do this whatever he's doing
now
yeah I just can't I can't look faster
cuz I just see Superman that's that's
what I see and I'm like I love them so
it's like you know you liked him a
Superman I did
a man that I felt like girls kind of dry
maybe he can pull this off it was just
kind of like I get why like so like even
when Sony had spider-man like stop
making the same spider-man yeah he was
he has other stories to tell besides
Superman lives Lana Lang
you know yeah I liked him in the Mission
Impossible movie used it
which arm cruise I thought it was a
great yeah now did you hear what they
doing that there's a possibility for the
third spider-man movie right right there
they said they're gonna definitely do it
but they're thinking it's gonna be a
spider-man vs. venom look how many times
yeah I think that's wasn't him I think
that's a I think that's a fan Theory I
don't think that's actually gonna happen
oh yeah yeah I heard they didn't want to
intertwine venom right series I hope not
probably because it's a lot more darker
that's cuz venom is not Disney you know
they haven't molded his characters
really don't wanna [ __ ] problem probably
but I was gonna tell you that on Netflix
that you gotta watch the ship show
that's so good yes it's all aimed yes
the chef show is the business and I know
like most of these places in LA that
they go to and they
and explained is really dope and then
breakfast lunch and dinner and then if
you want to watch something about super
entitled crazy white people watch shits
Creek it's pretty funny the chef's show
did you the the recipe they made for the
French onion soup how good did that
French onion soup look I like made good
French onion soup but it's not something
that I go to as like I can't wait to
have it I don't know I'm nothing I'm not
that way either but when I saw it I was
just like I'm gonna eat all of that
just give me at all no cheese no chai
like when they made the beignets and
then they made some white bammy sandwich
thing I really I really love the
interaction between the host and the MD
I was fault John yeah well Jon Favreau's
not the chef no no I know he's not the
shark he's the other guy I can't get the
chef's name he is like he's a character
oh yeah seeing him like this you're just
like you're like a little sponge Jude
you know his little his brain works in
such a way that he he could probably be
here on anything absorb and do it you
know yeah he's a director he's an actor
he does it all it's pretty pretty
amazing yeah does does anybody else have
any other questions do not I am good
okay so uh make me why don't you tell
everyone where we can find you and and
what's going on and your you know your
schedule and all that fun stuff by me on
twitch you can also find me on Twitter
way randomly sweet things awesome and I
do have an Instagram not very active but
you guys want to follow me oh you can do
that as well and as far as my schedule
it's
typically am streaming live Wednesday
Saturday between starting between 9:30
and 10:30 Pacific so you guys can catch
me there
shout out to the conquest I see y'all
down there in the chat thank you guys
for coming through to support la uh
sounds good I actually forgot to ask you
the one question that I usually like to
ask everybody which is if you could live
in a video game environment or world
what would it be
I probably ten to ten - so pretty
everywhere you went even ten ten was
pretty yeah that's actually my favorite
one yeah but yeah since they're kind of
intersected I was similar same old so
yeah yeah I really like that's one game
those two games ten intend to we're kind
of like my introduction the Final
Fantasy and I always just remember how
really pretty it looked I don't know
what it looks like now if I were to go
back but I think for its time you should
go back get it get it on Steam play it
they did really really good job with the
remaster for it oh nice nice yeah yeah I
actually played through it with my wife
so I wanted her to experience and she
liked it so well thank you guys for
having me I really appreciate it oh
thank you for coming really appreciate
you coming uh L you want to tell
everybody where you are your plugs yeah
so I'm on Twitter l-boogie Oh 208 and I
have the schedule it's the same as last
week and it's a pin tweet but it's
Tuesday through Friday 6 p.m. to 9 p.m.
and yeah so catch my mixer LBO to 8
everywhere Thank You MJ
you'd find me on Twitch Instagram
Twitter MJ's a boss snapchat yeah he's
the snapchat king I'm just saying that
old-school I catch me on twitter under
old school and lately you can catch me
on Lords of gaming dotnet and YouTube
under schools Tech Talk thank you and
myself now though SN a while L who I do
my schedule is gonna be a little wacky
this week cuz you know me being crazy
sick but yeah I will also be around
check out my Twitter you know just
squirt all that fun stuff I like to
thank everybody for coming tonight I
really appreciate you know coming in
that chat seeing and you know moving you
know makes me feel good thank you very
much we all appreciate it we'll have the
episode up Wednesday morning so when you
wake up from your you know from your
sleep you'll have it ready on you all
the different type of podcasts stuff you
know on your iTunes on your Google Play
on your Google podcasts on your Spotify
all that fun stuff if you have any
questions for anybody when we end up you
know having having these you can email
us at roundtable stream team at
gmail.com our Twitter is a table stream
we we end up always posting information
there about our guests that are coming
up when our podcast is live and things
like that and I would like to thank
loads of gaming dotnet and also the
ironn those podcasts you know for you
know helping us you know put it put this
out on the channel the iron loads
podcast is on on Sundays at 11:00 a.m.
Eastern you know check out like I said
check out loads of games at net they
have a lot of big articles we have some
big things happening in the background
I'm actually not a lot to talk about it
yet they actually told us I can't talk
about it so
but you'll you're gonna see some amazing
stuff happening on there very very
shortly and thank you very much again
everybody and remember everybody dream
big and keep on gaming thank you
everybody
I